[Música]
como le estábamos comentando ayer en
honduras se celebraron las elecciones
generales donde los ciudadanos eligieron
quién será el sucesor del presidente
saliente juan orlando hernández con el
recuento preliminar de los votos xiomara
castró entonces lidera con un 53 puntos
60 por ciento frente a nasry asfura del
gobernante partido nacional que obtiene
hasta el momento un 33 puntos 87 por
ciento de los sufragios según los datos
del consejo nacional electoral entonces
si se mantiene esta tendencia a castró
sería la sucesora de hernández que deje
el cargo con una serie de fallas entre
ellos varios casos de corrupción y
también vínculos con el narcotráfico y
una tasa de pobreza que alcanzaría el 75
por ciento de la población a finales de
lo que queda ya de este año 2021
entonces para ello quiero saludar a
reyna riviera ribera perdón ella es
abogada y analista política reina
gracias por estar con nosotros en
directo américa en francés 24 le
pregunto por el balance de la jornada
bueno primero buenos días gracias por la
oportunidad un saludo france24
efectivamente ayer fue una jornada
histórica por varias razones algunas de
esas ya la mencionaron ustedes primero
porque es la jornada más votada en la
historia de honduras se estima que
podría llegarse al 70 por ciento de
participación lo cual en los últimos
años no se ha elegido un presidente con
más del 31 por ciento de votos 32 por
ciento cuando mucho y en esta ocasión
posiblemente la señora xiomara castro de
zelaya llegue a un 53 54 por ciento por
lo menos eso es la tendencia actualmente
con 20 puntos arriba de diferencia del
partido oficialista partido nacional que
más o menos ahorita está bajo los por lo
menos los últimos conteos en un más o
menos un 33 por ciento casi 34 no luego
también es la primera mujer que sería
presidente en la historia de honduras y
en américa latina sería la virtual única
presidenta en funciones del continente
ahora reina entonces le pregunto si todo
esto se mantiene si omar acaso entonces
llegaría a la presidencia hondureña cuál
es el plan de gobierno las políticas que
implementaría xiomara castró y qué tan
difícil o fácil tendría la
gobernabilidad en el país
bueno con honduras es un país que viene
de datos y cifras estadísticas que
realmente son dramáticas en américa
latina por ejemplo somos el segundo país
más pobre después de haití recientemente
cifras oficiales señalaron que la
pobreza subió casi 6 puntos y la extrema
pobreza 10 puntos igualmente
también encontramos un país
ahogado por la situación de casos de
corrupción que se han denunciado en los
últimos años
las finanzas públicas han llegado a un
endeudamiento externo muy alto la
polarización también de años atrás hace
que sea un escenario complejo de
gobernabilidad la violencia también ha
incrementado en algunos puntos
manteniéndonos siempre en las cifras de
los de los países con mayores niveles de
violencia y de homicidios en américa
latina' en suma las cifras de honduras
no son nada halagadoras eso significa
que el gobierno de ese omar ha castro de
zelaya
qué hacer pactos para de gobernabilidad
principalmente tendrá que hacer pactos
con el sector empresarial con ella ha
propuesto la posibilidad de un gobierno
de integración nacional y un gobierno de
reconciliación uno de los temas que
posiblemente pueden ser más atractivos
de su plan de gobierno es que ya habla
de volver a restaurar una comisión
contra la impunidad para investigar
todos los temas de tráfico de influencia
de corrupción incrustados en el stade
cómo ir desmontando poco a poco esa
estructura de corrupción que
históricamente han limitado que se pueda
hacer inversión pública en favor de los
sectores más vulnerables entonces esos
son los escenarios ella también ha
levantado un discurso en favor de las
mujeres
tratando de señalar la necesidad que su
gobierno puedan haber políticas más
efectivas en temas de violencia contra
mujeres pero también de igualdad de
oportunidades con todos estos retos con
todo este complejo y complicado
o social
hondureño puede entonces la próxima
presidenta si es que se mantiene esta
tendencia que pues probablemente es así
va a ser xiomara castró puede resolver
alguno de estos problemas problemas
siendo realista a reina
siendo realista creo que ella va a
lograr un gobierno de altísima
integración de sectores sociales de
hecho en su campaña tuvo reuniones con
distintos sectores sindicalistas de
sectores empresariales sectores
cafetaleros las propias fuerzas armadas
que había sido un bastión muy fuerte del
presidente hernández etcétera no ella
creo que en primer lugar eso va a
necesitar honduras un gobierno que
realmente integre a todas sus mejores
cabezas por decirlo así a las personas
con mayores capacidades para poder
buscar salidas y avenidas para que
honduras vuelva a encontrar sendas de
desarrollo luego obviamente tiene un
escenario de finanzas públicas
bastante limitadas por un endeudamiento
externo pero hoy ha señalado que si su
gobierno se concentra en combatir la
corrupción y garantizar que la inversión
pública llegue a todos los sectores
sociales del país es posible entonces
que el país poco a poco encontrar rutas
para el desarrollo también ella se
define como un gobierno de transición
para poder avanzar hacia la ruta
democrática en el país no entonces ella
misma plantea mi gobierno no va a ser la
salida en el gobierno va a ser un
gobierno de transición para encontrar
después de tantos años de
señalamientos de corrupción en el estado
de señalamiento de
tráfico de influencia de influencias del
crimen organizado etcétera esos son los
grandes desafíos que ya tienen ahora
reina no quiero terminar esta
conversación sin preguntarle por el
presidente saliente juan orlando
hernández qué va a pasar con el señalado
de vínculos con el narcotráfico también
de corrupción que podría pasar con el
presidente saliente entonces
bueno en principio en lo paradójico es
que en el caso interno en honduras no
existe ninguna investigación contra el
presidente hernández a lo interno del
país sus señalamientos son
principalmente en las cortes de estados
unidos entonces prácticamente él tendría
que estar respondiendo frente a la
justicia estadounidense a falta de que
en honduras eso es parte de todo el
sistema impunidad que existe que hay que
revertir y no se ha hecho
investigaciones serias sobre los
principales casos de corrupción no
solamente al presidente hernández sino
de varios actores tanto de su gobierno
como actores también privados algunos
actores del sector privado entonces lo
más probable es que es si estás si los
fiscales de nueva york confirman una
acusación formal y va a tener que
responder a la justicia estadounidense